[Applause]
okay what do you think of tyson that's
what i want to ask you i mean it was
just great to see them both in there and
i just love tyson he's just such a
i think tyson is about to yeah i mean i
i kind of had a feeling it was going to
go that way i was like if he doesn't
connect connect he's not going to like
out box
roy yeah you know and uh but roy's chin
is is
unfortunately now at this stage of his
career not what he used to be you know
and uh i thought he was going to connect
he didn't connect and uh yeah it was
fine
did you see the post game interview
where jim gray asked roy how he was
doing and then mike was like
yeah i'm doing it and he seemed legit
angry was he
how playful was it how angry was he he
wasn't angry but it was interesting
because roy did have a fight within the
last few years yeah and tyson's like
i've been fun 15 years
yeah like but that's how much that's
like the esteem that we give
mike tyson yeah we're literally like
you're such a badass [ __ ]
yeah we're asking roy how is it to fight
tyson exactly yeah yeah and the thing
about tyson is like
it's really a testament to like people
who um
who drill well and by drill i mean like
just do repetitive movements like
if you looked at tyson it was slower but
he didn't look that different boxing
yeah did you notice that like his
movements in the ring were quite similar
to what we expected from and that's what
happens when you're [ __ ]
14 years old or whatever super soldier
and you just do the same thing
over and over ride a bike 100
yo hot take go if you re-watch that
fight
yeah count punches landed oh roy wins
roy wins that fight some people think
thank you that's right
that fight he won and he was trying to
win off points
yeah because that's yeah that's what i
thought that's the only way you can win
that fight because you can't even knock
each other out
yeah because even though tyson was
hitting them much harder and
and they were all being blocked yeah
maybe you got some body shots in there
but you're right yeah you're right
it's true it is interesting thank you
for saying that yeah
i mean i just yeah roy's just so great
but it was great to see them back in
there i don't know it's like
it's the least you could do i think
charlotte put on his caption and that
[ __ ] really
resonated with me but he was like the
amount of joy these guys have given me
in my life
just watching them both fight yeah
giving them fifty dollars couldn't even
compare
oh yeah yeah like i was so happy to give
them fifty dollars like
yeah and that's a donation they can make
a donation tax write-off
that's a charitable contribution real
talk man i mean
yeah i was happy as he might get a
million just like yo
go bro yeah take it everybody took from
you now you can take from everybody a
little bit
yeah so what's that what do you think
happens with this logan paul mayweather
thing
well first of all do you think
mayweather thinks he's fighting jake
i'm actually as i'm getting older
all white people are starting to become
the same yeah why is that
i don't know yeah it's like i'm actually
having a harder time distinguishing
white people yeah yeah so now i get it
yeah um so i had
10 years in severe brain damage then
imagine how long oh [ __ ]
so um i do think he's
he thought he's fighting the guy who
just fought nate you really think that i
think so
he's like oh yeah he's gotta have some
on his team though dude
why would he take this fight it makes
more sense that jake would fight him now
because jake has all the heat though
maybe they're trying to do like a
brother combo thing
you know i mean i don't know dude i hit
up logan i was like bro are you [ __ ]
this is crazy i was like i don't know
how you're gonna spin this because
they're gonna try to turn it into some
race war yeah if the fight is in
february it's during black history month
you are like the quintessential white
boy and yeah and like
that conversation happened with like
jake exactly i was gonna say that maybe
jake didn't want to take the fight
because he's like
i'm too easily vilifiable or whatever
whereas logan from what i understand is
like he's the clean cut all-american
it's harder to find the dirt on him
you're fighting him in black history
month and jake logan got dirt though
logan got the uh
suicide [ __ ] but against black people he
got dirt no
no so if you're fighting him during
black history month floyd don't care
about anybody but black people he's
pretty clear about that yeah
jake it seems like it'd be easier to
make him a villain and jake is probably
like look i don't want it i told him i
was like yo you can make tons of money
if you lean into that
but you're just gonna it's gonna be
horrible for your everyday yeah it's at
the expense of all your other money in
life
you're good but you could probably like
he could probably have a cash out fight
like literally you get 50 mil or
something crazy if he just leans into
like
not maga but you get close and then you
make it like this white versus black
thing
i think if you look up the highest
grossing fight in history
i think it's i think it's oh actually
now it's all changed because of
pay-per-view numbers and all that kind
of stuff but i think it was like
it was like muhammad ali versus some
like white dude
like there was some like racial tension
attached to it or maybe it was
mike tyson versus white guy do you
notice i'm looking up some now
well that guy's anyway peter mckinney or
whatever the [ __ ] that he knocked out in
60 seconds
was it that quick yeah i don't remember
that something the point is you can make
the most money there but i don't think
that's the right thing to do for him
brand wise
you know like but then again you have to
think about how the [ __ ] can you get
people to
think you have a chance in order for
them to buy the fight they either want
to see you get your ass
handed to you like get your ass beat
or they gotta think you have a chance so
how do you convince them
to think you have a [ __ ] chance
against the greatest great of all time i
don't know though because i could see
people
wanting to sign up just to see him get
knocked out like if you're like if you
don't like him or if you're someone that
like goes at him
i think i can see you like that's option
one of what i was saying oh but if you
want to profit the most off of that
you make everybody hate you logan's a
likable guy
right like i think most people like him
most people are into his stuff and they
like find the things that he do
uh does like funny and interesting right
like he's not a villain character
where i think jake you could say that he
might be a villain character there are
people that are like pushing back
you're nodding your head but if you have
the like the most listened to podcast in
the world
people don't hate listen for two hours
right so like
if you're listening it's because they
[ __ ] with you right
if you are an instagram comedian they're
[ __ ] that could
just literally watch it to be like look
how [ __ ] stupid these people are
or a bunch of like these girls who like
post sexy pictures whatever like that
they're not like
fans it's like nice to look at something
naked you know but
i think that he has legit fans what i'm
saying is if he wants to maximize
you basically become the heel
you know what i mean like you go colby
covington essentially that's what floyd
did initially to sell fights i think you
literally do the floyd technique
it's like floyd floyd is literally
wearing sombrero into the ring because
he wants every mexican
that exists to go i want this mexican
fighter to beat the [ __ ]
out of this black guy he does it on
cinco de mayo
fighting oscar de la hoya like he knows
what he's doing floyd only fought on
cinco de mayo
dude it was amazing and then like
bernard hopkins goes to puerto rico
takes the puerto rican flag rips it in
half and like steps on it when he was
fighting tito trinidad
yeah do you remember that and then of
course every puerto rican is like i want
you to beat the [ __ ] out of this guy
like creating
that kind of tension that like race war
is always going to drive up a fight
yeah i just don't know how the [ __ ]
anybody thinks that logan could have a
chance
he's got to release sparring footage
where he's actually knocking people out
like he's got to build up this ability
that he could actually fight
what's his size he's way bigger than
floyd he's 200 pounds
and he's solid the kid is solid and
shredded six feet maybe six one
200 [ __ ] pounds floyd is 150 pounds
160 pounds probably so that's his chance
right there
you can't hit him you can't hit the guy
you can't hit him i wonder if there's
something with this like have you ever
played basketball against someone that
sucks
actually me probably it's like you've
ever played a sport against someone that
you're good at that they're terrible at
yeah there's almost like a weird like
advantage
because like i don't think i play sagas
people that have never played and if you
try to do like a fake
you expect them to move that way you can
fake back but then sometimes you'll play
someone that doesn't move so you'll fake
and then you'll fake
back into where they go start interrupt
but to this point i thought and you said
it was head movement but maybe there's
something to this i'll ask again
when floyd fought conor it took him a
few rounds to get
to like get the upper hand for the first
few rounds it was like this is crazy
this is not like a clear-cut floyd
victory he just carried him and i
thought maybe conor was so
unorthodox that it was throwing off
floyd no he just cared there's no lucky
punchy thing
and even if he landed a lucky punch
logan
can't hit harder than the hardest person
that's hit floyd because even if you're
200 pounds
you don't have the power and precision
of a 154 pound fighter like
oscar de la hoya's hook is harder than
logan's
yeah probably you know what i mean so
it's like and i know what you're saying
and that's about someone who's really
unskilled at soccer or really unskilled
at basketball whatever
but with boxing logan's skilled
logan's had fights he actually knows the
technique right he knows what he's doing
in there you know i mean he's not just
going to go swing wild
it's uh it's tricky so we got to devise
a way to build this fight up because i
want it to be exciting
my wife is good at defending himself
though that's another thing it's like
it'd be if it'd be another thing if you
were going in there with a banger
like you're going there a boxer that's
known for just a complete slugfest
right then you got to puncher's chance
maybe because he's going to engage
you can't hit floyd exactly the greatest
fighters in history can't hit in my
opinion he's the greatest
at he's the greatest great of all time
meaning he's greater at boxing
than bill gates is at tech he's greater
at boxing than gretzky at hockey grants
get hockey he's the greatest great
you can't hit him i don't care he's 43.
he's gonna look a little [ __ ] if he
gets in there with a
non-professional and he's running but
here's the thing towards the end of his
career
he wouldn't run he'd stand right in
front of you and just use amazing
headphones that little shoulder roll
remember
right now is it possible logan can win
without winning
so that's the other thing i was thinking
right it's like how do you
how do we create okay he can win without
winning but i don't know if that sells
tickets
so in other words if he finds a way to
go the distance with floyd
right right people will go wow he
actually went the distance with floyd
floyd
get him out of here but you're not
selling the tickets
and who gives a [ __ ] about a moral
victory when you're in there getting
your ass kicked yeah
right but is it like is there rematch
money in it is there like some type of
like can he make a prediction that he
can't come through on like yo i'm gonna
stick you about in the fifth or whatever
like
so tricky it's so tricky because what is
he going to say i'm going to land one
punch
yeah i guess honestly floyd if he really
wants to sell this fight
he's got to say he's not going to land a
single punch
so you create that's a good point you
create the expectation
of not victory
we're not we know who's going to win but
how do i shift what a win
is right yeah like if you're playing
basketball it's like against someone
amazing like oh i won't beat you but
yo i'm going to break your ankles and
you knock him down it's like oh yeah he
did what he said he was gonna do look at
jay williams
yeah i beat jay williams because of what
he
decided was the competition right so
technically
yeah floyd could create a competition
where logan could win at least in the
eyes of the people
everybody listen his podcast right now
knows how to bust jay williams ass
even though he busts my ass
it was 6-1 but it wasn't yeah it was 7-6
yeah so that's what they got to create